في قصتنا الفن الفلسطيني المقاول نحاول
تلمس تفاعلي كافه الفنون الفلسطينيه مع
العمل الثوري للحركات الوطنيه وكيف ساهمت
في تعريف العالم بها من خلال تجارب
لفنانين فلسطينيين في الوطن
[موسيقى]
ما اهميه الفن فعلا كاداه للمقاومه وتثبيت
الحق الفلسطيني امام غطرسه الاحتلال للفن
دور عظيم في الحفاظ على تماسك
الفسيفساء بين ابناء الشعب الواحد نحن في
اشد الحاجه لدور الفن الجمعي الذي يشمل
الجميع من خلال من خلال ادوات بسيطه
ساعدنا على لم الشمل
يوثق مسيره الشعب زي ما وفق الوالد
والوالد طبعا مسيره الشعب الفلسطيني منكبه
الى الى انطلاق الكفاح المسلح
والثوره الفلسطينيه في السبعينيات
والستينيات من القرن الماضي الشعوب التي
تنتج ثقافه هي الشعوب التي تكتب تاريخا
اهميه فن الكاريكاتير بالنسبه لك ايضا من
منطقه كغزه كيف ترينها وكيف يتمثل فنك
المقاول تعد يعني سلاح قوي جدا في المعركه
ضد المحتل كيف لا ورسوماتنا دوما توضع
عليها العين الصهيونيه تتابع كل ما يرسمه
الفنان الفلسطيني فن ساهم بشكل كبير في
فضح ممارسات الاحتلال ادافع عن قضيه ليس
برصاص بل من خلال ريشه ملء العقبات التي
تعترضكم ربما في تثبيت الحق الفلسطيني عن
طريق الفن من قبل الاحتلال كفنان فلسطينيه
اللي ولدت في ال 48 كابنه للناصره
نحن نعاني الامرين لانه احنا
عشنا وولدنا في واقع متناقض احنا بدنا
نحافظ على تواصلنا مع هويتنا الجمعيه مع
باقي الشعب الفلسطيني بواقع فرض فرض عليك
انك تحملي وثائق رسميه لا تمثلك ولا تعبر
عن هويتك ذكرنا بانك ايضا تقوم بنوع من
المقاومه من خلال ارشبت هذا الموروث المهم
الذي يثبت وجود الانسان الفلسطيني الاقدم
من اي وجود اخر لماذا توجه الى هذا
الموضوع ما اهميته ان يهيمن على الارشيفات
يؤثر في كتابه التاريخ وهذا من هذا
المنطلق يعمل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على على يعني الهيمنه
على الارشيفات فقط فتح المواد اللي هو
معني في الفتحات الارشيفات الفلسطينيه
يعني اللي تخصنا وين موجوده هل هي في
ايادي فلسطينيه هل ممكن نحافظ عليها
للاجيال القادمه وهم بحسيت انه في مشكله
هذه الارشيفات وهذا الموروث المسموع
والمرئي يعني ليس في ايادي فلسطينيه وجزء
كبير منه ليس في ايادي فلسطينيه في كل رسم
كاريكاتير يعني يتردد توقيعك وبصمتك التي
يعرفها الجميع وهي المفتاح العوده يعني ما
الرساله باعتقادك الابلغ ربما من هذا
التوقيع عرفته ان يبقى اشاره الى اننا لن
نتخلى عن قضيتنا الفلسطينيه ولم نتخلى عن
ارضنا وحقنا في ارضنا لم يحتفظ اجدادي
بمفتاح
لابقى اتمسك به فجعلت هذا المفتاح رمزا
لكل فلسطيني باذن الله عائدون الى ترابنا
من النهر الى البحر باذن الله
[موسيقى]